get on the Knicks bandwagon they got a
new star in town and Kevin Knox mark
Berman covers the Knicks he's their beat
writer New York Post and joins us from
Las Vegas go back to draft night mark
the reaction of the crowd and the
reaction you had when the Knicks took
Kevin Knox well I mean I I knew that
Michael Porter jr. was probably gonna
fall to them and I was told that you
know the medical reports were were scary
and and the fans are chanting for
Michael Porter jr. but you know they
haven't seen the medical reports and the
rest of the league has so it really was
between bridges mikkel bridges and Kevin
Knox and you know everyone's seen so
much of bridges you know during the
Villanova's run to the championship and
and Kevin Knox was kind of an up and
down season Kentucky you know had some
struggles this year so you know the fans
booed but it's almost like that's what
you do at the draft night if you're a
Knicks fan porzingis obviously got booed
many many others have but now they're
delighted he's really taking Las Vegas
by storm he struggled yesterday against
a tough defender of the Celtics Elijah
way but he's you walk around the gym and
the arena and scouts just come up to me
and say wow the Knicks really got a good
one
when did the buzz start with us I mean
it really was the the opening game he
was driving in the basket
getting the free throw line his
three-point shot looked looked nice it
wasn't always following that first game
but a couple of sensational dunks in the
open court so much athleticism he's just
fun to watch he's got that alpha in him
that you can't teach and even on his off
night yesterday against the Celtics he
still puts up 15 points I mean even on a
bad night he's still going to put up
numbers he's just got that scorers
mentality and at Kentucky you saw it
once in a while but I don't Calipari
plays a different offense
the spacing is different in the NBA he's
an NBA player maybe he wasn't a great
college player but he is an NBA player
what is let's look at the the immediate
future here so when the season starts
porzingis status will be what yeah he's
gonna still be rehabbing my estimate
right now and the next have given no
estimate but my estimate is sometime
around Christmas at the earliest
they want to play it really cautious
they'll know more in September when it
comes back from Europe he's been
rehabbing and Real Madrid so even when
he comes back though around Christmas
and that's my prediction you know he'll
be in a minute's limit probably 20
minutes a night for a while the Knicks
by then might be you know out of a
playoff race you know this is going to
be a young rebuilding team unless all
these young guys really step up early so
who knows and maybe they shut him down
late in the season they just want to
prove to the 2019 free agents porzingis
is healthy and he's ready to be a super
store our Knick fans to patient I think
in some way you know everyone says you
can't rebuild in New York but Knicks
fans I'm amazed at how well they're
taking this five-year playoff drought
and it's not just no playoffs the last
five years the last four years on March
1st they have been out of it and there's
been a lot of meaningless games of the
garden and it's just amazing the fans
are still packing them in listen there's
a lot of tourists that go to games now
now that they're more available on the
market but the fans have been just I
think the Knicks organization should be
so thankful to this fan base sticking
with them and now there's this
excitement here in July
you know because Kevin Knox and even
their second round pick Mitchell
Robinson a project Center he's blocking
shots galore
he's very active he's scoring garbage
buckets I mean they got they did really
well in this draft or so it seems in
July why can't you get free agents to
the Garden
well I'll be this year you know they
didn't have the caps this joy there was
no cap space everything is about 2019 so
you know they get Mariota Sonya who is a
lottery pick from 2015 and you know
Scott Perry the GM for the next helped
draft him in Orlando so they he has a
lot of belief in him but there was no
major cap space it's all about 19 and if
they strike out in 2019 then you got a
wonder while the garden has really lost
its allure New York City no longer is
the mecca I mean you could go to you
know Oklahoma City and become a
superstar so well it's gonna be very
telling Kyrie Irving is from the New
York area I know people have said he
would love to play for the Knicks
whether it works out or not who knows he
wants to join forces with Jimmy Butler
I'm told and the Knicks are not going to
have that type of cap spaceman do max
players so that could really hurt them
but you know herbing put the Knicks on
his wish list last summer
he was one of the Knicks were one of
four teams on carries wish list should
be fun enjoy the summer league the rest
of it mark we appreciate your time thank
you
all right mark Berman New York Post
Knicks beat right four more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]